probablemente estés familiarizado con el
término de factor por ejemplo si dijera
cuáles son los factores del número 12 es
decir nos estamos preguntando qué número
entero puedo multiplicar por otro número
entero y qué tal resultado nos dé 12 así
que por ejemplo podría tener 1 por 12
verdad esto nos da 12 también y entonces
diríamos que 1 es un factor de 12 y 12
también es un factor de 12 verdad
también podríamos decir que 2 por 6 nos
da 12 y entonces decimos que tanto 2
como 6 son factores de 12 también
tenemos otro caso que 3 por 4 nos da 12
y nuevamente decimos que 3 y 4 son
factores de 12 verdad entonces si
preguntamos cuáles son los factores de
12 podemos decir que los factores son 1
2 3 4 6
y 12 son todos los factores que tiene 12
muy bien entonces también podríamos
decirlo de otra forma es más vamos a
agarrar el 3 como un ejemplo y podemos
decir que 3 es un factor de 12 3 es un
factor de 12 y hay otra forma de decir
esto mismo pero con otras palabras es
decir pensando ahora en 12 12 es
divisible entre 3 divisible entre 3
ahora bien lo que quiero hacer es
extender esta idea de factores y
divisibilidad al mundo algebraico por
ejemplo digamos que tenemos un mono mió
el mono mió 3x ya y que multiplicamos
por el mono mió digamos menos 2 x
cuadrada
kubica lo importante de este producto es
que ambos coeficientes son enteros ahora
bien si queremos resolver primero
tenemos que multiplicar los coeficientes
menos 6
a 3 x menos 2 sería menos 6 verdad ahora
multiplicamos las x y tendremos x x x
cuadrada será x cúbica y ahora
multiplicamos por ye kubica y nos da ya
a la 4 entonces de esta misma forma como
tenemos dos monos que al multiplicarlos
nos da otro mono mió podemos decir lo
siguiente que 3x y esto es un mono mió
es un factor pero va a ser un factor de
quien es un factor de el mono mió que
hemos obtenido que en este caso será
menos 6x cúbica de cuarta y de forma
similar a como teníamos esta expresión
podemos decir que menos 6x cúbica de
cuarta es divisible entre
divisible divisible entre el mismo
factor verdad podríamos poner cualquiera
de estos dos factores pero bueno vamos a
poner 3x y muy bien así que espero que
veas la similitud que hay con el caso de
los números enteros verdad si tengo
estos dos monos y los multiplico
obtenemos otro mono mío verdad y
entonces estos dos monómeros serían
factores o bien podemos decir que este
tercer mono mío verdad es divisible
entre cualquiera de estos dos monos y
también podemos extender la misma idea a
binomios o polinomios por ejemplo vamos
a hacer un poco de espacio digamos que
tengo el binomio x + 3 que multiplica a
otro binomio digamos x + 7 verdad
entonces si nosotros queremos obtener el
resultado simplemente multiplicamos x
por equis y nos da x cuadrada luego
tendremos 3 por equis y 7 por equis eso
nos da un total de
x y finalmente tengo 3 x 7 que es 20 1
muy bien entonces podemos decir que
cualquiera de estos dos binomios verdad
es un factor de este trinomio o podemos
decir también que el trinomio es
divisible entre cualquiera de estos dos
binomios así que por ejemplo vamos a
hacerlo con el x 7 muy bien vamos a
hacer con x + 7
podemos decir que x + 7 es un factor es
un factor de nuestro trinomio que
tenemos aquí verdad que es x cuadrada
más 10 x más 21 de la misma forma
podemos decir que x cuadrada más 10 x
más 21 en este caso es divisible es
divisible entre cualquiera de los dos
factores que tenemos el azul o el
amarillo en este caso estamos hablando
del amarillo así que
/ x 7 entonces en resumen la clave de
todo esto que hemos estado haciendo es
que estamos trabajando con polinomios de
coeficientes enteros es decir todos los
números que acompañan a nuestros
polinomios son números enteros